[Musique]
alors on a choisi de transformer la peau
de poisson en cuir parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est un déchet que jette l'industrie
agroalimentaire et la restauration et la
vente âge du poisson du squames a
notamment c'est qu'il un grain qui est
unique
il a une des plus grandes résistances
syndicales les plus résistants au monde
aujourd'hui tout en ayant une grande
souplesse
[Musique]
une fois que la peau de poisson quittent
le restaurant où elle vers la rive
congelés on enlève la chaire résiduelles
avec avec une et chercheuse pour ensuite
passer dans un foulon qui est une
machine à laver rotative qui va pouvoir
imprégner le cuir de tanins avant dure
environ une à deux semaines avant de
passer sur les finitions où on va venir
ajuster les teintes et les coloris est
également pressé le cuir pour avoir un
pur parfaitement lisse à la fin de du
procès de production
[Musique]